قبل قليل كان هناك عده رشقات صاروخيه
استهدفت مدينه كوبيراسك في خاركيف السلطات
الاقليميه او المحليه هناك تقول ان هذا
القصف استهدف البنيه التحتيه واصفر عن
عصابه بعض الاشخاص ايضا الهجمات والمعارك
على اشدها في مخموت مجموعات فاغنر وكذلك
ايضا الجيش الروسي وكذلك من الناحيه
الاخرى الجيش الاوكراني هناك معارك يعني
حرب شوارع تدور في انحاء مختلفه من
المدينه القوات الروسيه تريد السيطره باي
طريقه ممكنه على هذه المدينه في اسرع وقت
ممكن كذلك ايضا هناك تعزيزات تحاول الوصول
او تحاول القاده العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ايصالها الى الجنود الاوكران في هذه
المنطقه
هذه التعزيزات هي هامه للغايه الجيش
الاوكراني يقول ان طريقه التعزيزات مازال
مفتوحا حتى الان لكن المتوقع يعني وفقا
لما ن من
القياده العسكريه هنا ان شيئا قويا سيحدث
في خلال الايام القادمه لكن جدير بالذكر
راويه ان اقوى يعني القوات الاوكرانيه
المقاتله واكثرها خبره هي التي تقاتل في
الجانب الشرقي في محمود وكذلك في دنيتك
وكذلك ايضا في خاركيف
التي نتحدث منها الان يعني كما تشاهدين من
خلفي هناك دمار كبير اصاب هذه المدينه
هناك اكبر المقابر الجماعيه موجوده في هذه
المدينه قتل اكثر من 2000 مواطن مدني بعد
ان قامت القوات الروسيه باحتلال هذه
المدينه لمده سبعه اشهر متواصله نجحت على
اثرها بعد ذلك
القوات الاوكرانيه في دحر القوات الروسيه
وسترى مره اخرى على المدينه حتى ان الرئيس
الاوكراني زينسكي بنفسه
قام برفع العالم الاوكراني مره اخرى على
هذه المدينه واحد اشهر المباني المدينه
بصفه عامه يمكن القول ان المعارك تبقى
مستمره بصوره كبيره وقويه خاصه في المنطقه
او مناطق والجبهات الشرقيه المسيرات
الاوكرانيه تقول القياده العسكريه انها
تحاول استهداف تجمعات عسكريه الروسيه في
اكثر من منطقه